this morning facebook releases its first
ever threat report on efforts to spread
political misinformation on its platform
the company removed more than 150
so-called influence operations
after criticism that it failed to block
russian interference back in 2016.
senior investigative correspondent
katherine herrod spoke exclusively with
facebook
about the findings catherine good
morning to you what's the big takeaway
here
well gail the nearly 40-page report
reviewed by cbs news found a growing
number of groups right here at home
manipulating information for political
and financial gain
facebook also stresses the problem is
very real in
other countries leading up to the 2020
campaigns
facebook investigators found election
meddling by
traditional adversaries like russia and
iran was compounded by
new efforts to distort the facts that
was actually one of the big surprises
nathaniel gleicher is facebook's head of
security policy
domestic manipulation and foreign
interference are both serious challenges
and you have to tackle them both at the
same time it's not just u.s elections
according to the report facebook has
identified influence operations that
came
from over 50 countries in 30 languages
on every continent except antarctica in
the united states
we see these types of activities linked
to marketing firms
linked to sort of political actors and
links to fringe groups or conspiracy
theory groups
what does domestic interference look
like imagine a pr firm
or a marketing firm that hires a
thousand people in the united states
to use their social media accounts or
maybe create fake social media accounts
to advocate for particular issues or on
behalf of a particular candidate
glacier said facebook started
identifying and taking down such
operations in 2017
among the threats facebook observed were
so-called perception hacks
designed to undermine voter confidence
one of the key claims we see people make
is that they've hacked
election systems these are simply people
playing on the fear that that might have
happened
they're trying to weaponize uncertainty
and weaponize
our own fears for a lay person it's hard
to know what's
real what's trustworthy what would you
say to them
ask who's reporting it who's behind it
how much do you know about them and can
you get some of that additional context
and the report predicts more targeted
attacks in the future
exploiting political divisions because
these influence operations capitalize
on fear and uncertainty the face report
comes as president biden is set to meet
middle of next month with the russian
president vladimir putin
anthony catherine thank you